comme un petit pouvoir nous et michelin
de vue et nous avons rendez vous jeudi
prochain une audio tout ce qui s'était
passé
la soupe est bonne en général non
seulement l'aspect bal des groupes sont
franches vous avez l'habitude vous
monsieur je crois de la cuisine
militaire puisque vous avez passé une
trentaine d'années dans l'armée mais la
cuisine d'un général alors mise surtout
la cuisine popote et rarement à la table
de généraux le mari de valérie andré un
ancien colonel de l'armée de l'air s'est
rarement assis à la table des généraux
aujourd'hui c'est chose faite madame le
médecin général lui a préparé ce midi
des tomates et la salade mal à ces zones
est paraît-il avant de retourner à sa
base arrête ses deux étoiles
la première général de l'armée française
avoue bien volontiers qu'elle n'est pas
un cordon bleu
[Musique]
vous êtes resté très simple pour un
général pas de chauffeur pas des deux
camps en fait à part vos étoiles vous
êtes parce qu'une femme comme les autres
mais j'espère bien être une femme comme
les autres ce n'est pas parce que je
suis médecin général que j'ai
l'intention de changer quoi que ce soit
dans ma manière d'être
et est ce que vous croyez que vous avez
eu beaucoup de chance de devenir général
ou au contraire est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est le cheminement normal de votre
carrière
je vous dirais que je me suis toujours
donné à fond pour mon métier j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance d'avoir un métier qui
m'a autant passionné et même avant tout
je reconnais que on ne peut pas on ne
devient pas systématiquement général et
à ce moment là oui je purge si vous
voulez j'ai beaucoup de chance
cette petite femme frêle et souriante ne
doit pas seulement ses étoiles à la
chambre né en 1922 à strasbourg elle
s'est engagée à l'âge de 25 ans comme
médecin capitaine en indochine
on commande des hélicoptères ou des
avions qu'elle apprend à piloter
elle participe à 120 missions de guerre
en extrême-orient et assurent
l'évacuation de cent soixante cinq
blessés en algérie
elle effectue 365 mission comme médecin
et killer malgré la fois rouge fans sur
son appareil
on ne l'épargnait pas dit elle lors des
évacuations sanitaires breveté
parachutiste décoré de la croix de
guerre avec cette citation commandeur de
la légion d'honneur
valérie andré totalise trois mille deux
cents heures de vol
aujourd'hui le général n'a pas perdu la
main
[Musique]
très tôt jusqu'à présent assez vigilant
général dans l'armée française
cachant ses vues autour de vous après
cette nomination de la jalousie
je partage que lors des technologies par
la vie dure il doit dans la vie comme
dans d'autres des bombes correctionnelle
en ciel ouvert conclu
et ce côté l'équipage mais un jour qui
te fait un peu général d'iris de
l'opération coeur et je ne devrais pas
vrai d'abord que nous retirons à papier
les enfants peuvent se produire
il faudrait d'abord savoir se présenter
puis confié valérie andré pouvait
espérer obtenir ces deux étoiles en 1975
lors de l'année de la femme
le gouvernement aura préféré entendre
son anniversaire pour la nommer général
le jour même où weylandt dans sa 55e
année
[Musique]